[Musik]
kleinkriminalität das verbinden viele
mit bushido berlin neukölln und der
serie vblocks doch in der realität ist
die kleinkriminalität nicht etwas
romantisches sondern einfach nur
grauenvoll gestern versammelten sich in
duisburg bis zu 100 männer in zwei
gruppen dass wir in schüsse menschen
wurden teilweise schwer verletzt und ein
großeinsatz folgte beteiligt sowohl
einen klaren mit ableger in berlin
gewesen sein unser thema heute abend
kleinkriege in deutschland verlieren wir
die kontrolle oder bevor im polizei und
medien seien kleinkriminalität
rassistische vorurteile und meine gäste
heute abend der bundesvorsitzenden
deutschen polizeigewerkschaft rainer
wendt rpg für maximale härte im umgang
mit kleinkriminalität und findet die
clans sollen den staat fürchten der
gründer der arche bernd siggelkow der
seit jahren gegen kinderarmut und
vernachlässigung kämpft wenn es nach ihm
geht sollten die politiker mehr geld in
das bildungssystem und nicht immer in
die familienpolitik stecken journalist
yorker vor der einst selbst als
flüchtling in die bundesrepublik
deutschland kam und zwei jahre lang in
einem arbeiterwohnheim in berlin gold
köln gelebt hat er war der einzige
deutsche unter den ausländern sein
spitzname war professor ein mann schön
dass sie da sind antonia jamin ist
deutsch israelischen journalisten und
chefreporterin leitbild sie wird uns
berichten ob es in deutschland no go
areas gibt und damit herzlich willkommen
meine damen und herren zu einer
spezialausgabe von viertel nach acht
fangen wir einmal den jüngsten
ereignissen nrw event war das jetzt ein
einzelfall oder nur die spitze des
eisbergs das wäre ja schön wenn das ein
zufall während wir haben uns ja fast
schon daran gewöhnt in berlin am
hellichten tag werden leute erschossen
erstochen in duisburg ist es auch kein
einzelfall tut mir besonders für meine
heimatstadt dass es dort so zugeht aber
es ist längst schon traurige realität
nicht nur in großstädten geworden das
klärt sich auf offener straße so
austoben und nicht nur das auch dass sie
ganz öffentlich und ziemlich ungeniert
ihre macht demonstrieren diese
mittlerweile haben hacker frau hat man
das kommen sehen diese spaltung und
diese kleinkriminalität also ob das
wirklich nur noch kleinkriminalität ist
war ich zu bezweifeln in der
klassifizierung dahinter haben wir doch
fest gefügten strukturen mittlerweile
die auch uns großen gewerblichen sinne
kriminalität betreiben nur ich möchte
ihnen gleich zu beginn etwas unorthodox
es sagen ich mich regt das nicht
besonders auf ich weiß nicht was die
deutschen haben alle großen städte in
allen westlichen demokratien haben
solche zentren in new york wird am tag
drei viermal geschossen das ist
überhaupt abend in den news überhaupt
gar kein thema in london gibt es street
games das gibt es in los angeles viertel
die sind der südosten von los angeles da
können sie gar nicht mehr hin als normal
ja ich wir wollen eine großstadt sein
und wir wollen eine offene gesellschaft
sein und da können wir nicht zahlen
spielen
also hat die klangqualität in den
letzten jahren zugenommen aber natürlich
aber es soll nicht besonders ich kann
damit keinen grund von aufregung sind
also das gehört zu einer freien
gesellschaft
bitte sagen einfach ok damit sein dass
sich sein gewinn dass eine gesellschaft
vielfältig ist und dass auch das
dazugehört einmal freien gesellschaft
ist die kriminalität eine erscheinung
mit der man leben muss in gesellschaften
in denen es keine kriminalität gibt
sitzen die kriminellen in der regierung
wie in moskau und da gibt es
kontrollierte kriminalität durch die
regierung wenn sie eine gesellschaft
ohne kriminalität wollen müssen die
diktatur haben ist eine offene
gesellschaft wir können geschäfte
treiben und da hat auch der böse seine
chance aber hier gibt es ja auch
hintergrund also dass diese leute sind
ja nicht
also die haben einen hinter prozent
tatsächlich glauben ganz deutlich und
das gute ich nicht ein außerdem ist das
völlig falsch was sie sagen auch
freiheitliche gesellschaften offener
gesellschaften haben einen starken staat
verdiente die schwachen in dieser
gesellschaft schützt den kriminalität
die diebe stellen sich nicht
untereinander sondern es gibt immer auch
opfer wenn jetzt erzählen sie einfach
nicht drin es märchenstunde
entschuldigung hier haben der polizei
ist in diesem staat schützt jeglicher
richtung ja ja der staat hat die
gesetzliche verpflichtung und erstarrt
guckt weg ich habe in köln erlebt da
kommt kein polizist zu sehen weil sie
angst haben vor die hand nahm und folk
ist ja sie erzählen sie keine
passacaglia und fuge in berlin sind 1000
mal 1000 polizei würde sie wirklich
bitten hängung zu sagen ja auch nicht
beleidigen sie heißen hier ein wenig und
viel arbeit es ist deutsche und andere
hören
es stehen
in dem sich nicht mehr hintrauen das
stimmt nicht es gibt es so etwas nicht
sagen deutschland es gibt ja sage ich
sie herzlich ein zu einem spaziergang
wir berlin nicht denn eines scheint
einmal hierüber zu herr siegel gibt ist
no go areas oder nicht also ich finde es
erst mal gewagt zu sagen wir müssen uns
damit abfinden dass es in einer
gesellschaft oder in einer großstadt in
einer metropole
gang kriminalität gibt ich bin selber
aus der pulle als kind aufgewachsen da
war gab es auch längst da hat man sich
nicht dran gewöhnt und natürlich gibt es
no go areas es gibt gegenden tatsächlich
wo die polizei nicht so präsent ist wie
sie eigentlich sein sollte was es
geschafft weil gar nicht genug geld
dafür ist bei der stadt einfach nicht
genug geld in die hand nicht mehr
anlaufstellen sei der ausblick jetzt
rede ich aber gerne auch auf der anderen
seite gibt es natürlich auch gründe
warum menschen in gangs landen oder auf
der straße bleibt auf der strecke
bleiben weil eben nicht genug getan wird
weil nicht genug hingeschaut wird ich
selber der auf der straße auch groß
geworden ist würde mit diesem argument
was sie sagen nicht klarkommen weil ich
habe auch auf die schnauze gefallen ich
habe auch auf die stolzen gericht aber
ist das die antwort nein ist nicht die
antwort wir müssen etwas tun wir müssen
als gesellschaft auch als menschen auf
sie und ich wir müssen vorbilder sein
damit menschen anders reagieren als wir
als als was sie gerade sagen und ich
glaube wenn wir besondere polarisierung
leben und sagen okay wir sind jetzt
berlin wir müssen so sein wie new york
oder los angeles wer sind wir denn
entweder haben wir klare regeln wir
haben klare vorbilder wir haben klare
grenzen oder nicht und ich will kein
polizeistaat gar keine frage aber wir
brauchen regeln und menschen brauchen
regeln und sagt ja den lösungsansätzen
und den regeln kommen wir gleich noch
ich möchte einmal antonia fragen gibt es
denn für dich no go areas hast du schon
etwas erlebt selbst ja also ich muss das
mal klar sagen ich als jüdin und ich als
jüdische frau es gibt stadtteile in
berlin neukölln zum beispiel dass ich
selber ganz alleine oder sogar mit
freunde nicht betreten werden werde
entweder jetzt vor ort wegen
berichterstattung und tatsächlich in den
zwei jahren in denen ich ohne vor ort
war in köln wegen berichterstattung ich
habe mich in wie in mein mikrofon auch
geredet wurde ich zweimal angegriffen
mit einem dollar
einmal gab es genug polizei aber die
haben den vorfall überhaupt nicht
gesehen die polizei hat im nachhinein
auch ermittelt aber in den zwei mal hat
man die täter niemals gekriegt ob wenn
du hast sogar die täter fotografiert hat
er sagt ja also die im ersten mal war
waren die täter sehr klar im bild zu
sehen wochen danach habe ich einfach
eine meldung gekommen
wir schließen wir schließen das und ja
und ich habe jetzt auch vor kurzem eine
tochter bekommen und ich kann dir klar
sagen dass ich mich meine tochter jetzt
auch meine jüdische tochter jetzt nicht
in köln einfach so spazieren gehen werde
ärger freude da ist auch die spanne
frage sollten wir das auch einfach
akzeptieren also kommentiert wir sollten
das nicht akzeptieren ich war nur für
ihre illusionen das sollte ich sagen
dass in einer stadt von der größe
berlins von dem wirtschafts umschlag von
den geldmengen die hier unterwegs sind
das in einer freien gesellschaft und
nicht einer friedhofs gesellschaft dass
es dort wirklich es wirklich dazu kommen
kann kriminalitäts frei zu leben im
übrigen gibt es ganz andere form von
white collar kriminalität gießen in den
feinen restaurants zu machen eine
rechnung für 1000 euro am abend und
drehen ganz andere dinge verstehen sie
also wir so ich bin dagegen dass wir
diese art plakative demokratie
hochspielen dass neukölln betrifft
wirklich ihnen etwas erzählen was sie
jetzt bestürzen wird ich habe in einem
haus gelebt wo fast nur männer lebt und
abends traf man sich in der shisha bar
und ich wunderte mich dass niemand eine
maske trägt
und ich sage haben sie keine angst oder
habt ihr die sagen ja bruder bruder
keines von corona da wurde mir gesagt
aller schickt immer nur ein todfeind zur
gleichen zeit und ich sage auch so wäre
es sind der andere wer ist denn schon da
der jude das kriegen sie offen gesagt in
einem neuköllner restaurant und da sind
die gleichen leute die von der polizei
mit verlaub ungestört durch berlins
straßen laufen können und ihr seid weg
gerufen
dann sehen sie deswegen mache ich diese
ganze ganze klar da einig mit wir haben
eine szenerie die offen gewalttätig ist
die antisemitisch auftritt er dreht er
und nicht nur da auch die linkspartei
jugendliga hat gefordert israel weg als
start haben sich die polizei
eingreifen wie ist die situation erst
einmal single kommt ja völlig recht dass
die polizei nicht in dem maße im
öffentlich noch präsent ist wie wir uns
das wünschen das hat etwas mit
personellen möglichkeiten zu tun das hat
etwas auch mit technischen möglichkeiten
zu tun und viele andere mehr insofern
gebe ich ihnen recht da ist ein defizit
das wir seit vielen jahren beklagen auch
und gerade in berlin und nicht nur dort
und
aber dann müssen wir über das thema no
go areas nochmal in der definition
sprechen in mit no go areas bezeichnen
viele menschen gebiete in die die
polizei nicht hinein geht weil sie angst
hat und ich behaupte noch einmal das
mögen sie bestreiten ich behaupte noch
mal diese gebiete gibt es in ganz
deutschland nicht es gibt wohl die
gebiete in die wir nicht mit einem
streifenwagen hinein fahren sondern
erstmal in gruppen fahrzeug heranziehen
oder eine ganze hundertschaft war zwar
im öffentlichen dienst aber nicht
bescheuert sind oder lebensmüde weil man
sonst nicht da rein fahren kann deshalb
müssen manchmal kräfte zusammengezogen
werden und dass das versammlungsrecht in
berlin angeht und die versammlung soweit
in berlin entschuldigung dieser
rechtlichen möglichkeiten hat nicht die
polizei gemacht deshalb sagen sie mich
die polizei duldet essen sondern der
gesetzgeber und die justiz schreiben uns
bestimmte dinge vor auch im
versammlungsrecht da kann die polizei
das ist keine geschmacksfrage für die
polizei sondern sie muss sich an die
gesetzlichen vorgaben und auflagen der
gerichte honig aus wenn ich das sagen
darf was ist jetzt mit diesem logo
airways also warum wurde antonia nicht
geholfen warum ist es in neukölln so
dass antonia sagt sie würde dort also
dort jetzt in diesem bereich nicht
hingehen weil erstens die polizei nicht
zu jeder zeit an jedem ort sind
gleichzeitig sein kann dass der erste
punkt der zweite punkt ist weil die
polizei nicht für die einstellung von
strafverfahren zuständig ist das ist die
staatsanwaltschaft da muss man dann auch
die staatsanwaltschaft fragen darf weil
die polizei kann nur die beweise erheben
sie können beweise sichern zeugen von
dem alles mögliche machen aber für die
entscheidung im strafverfahren ist sie
schlicht wirklich zu stören aber ich
muss schon sagen das letzte mal dass es
passiert ist letzter mai als letztes
jahr da gab es dieses riesen riesa demo
also die pro palästinensische demo es
gab es die polizei war vor ort ich wurde
angegriffen es wurde auch gedreht also
es war sehr groß auch und also ich habe
einfach keinen polizisten gesehen danach
bin ich auch wieder nach hause gegangen
weil es war einfach zu viel für mich und
dann habe ich aber von kollegen erfahren
dass die demo total also im chaos gering
ist also die die idee die die die
palästinenser haben da die polizisten
angegriffen und umgekehrt und das dach
leider immer wieder und glauben sie mir
niemand beklagt dass mehr als ich das in
berlin jeden tag 20 polizistinnen und
polizisten angegriffen werden und
teilweise schwer verletzt werden das ist
in berlin die realität mit der ich
übrigens mich nicht abfinden werde
niemals aktiven haben weil wir nicht
genügend polizisten haben weil
polizisten zu wenig dürfen weil
polizisten mit viel zu viel
nebensächlichkeiten mit klimbim
unterwegs sind und weil polizisten auch
und gerade in berlin nicht den
notwendigen politischen rückhalt haben
hier haben wir eine regierung die tag
und nacht damit beschäftigt ist der
polizei zu erklären dass in rassistische
korrupte schlägerbande ist und wir
entsprechende gesetze machen müssen
damit beschäftigt sich die berliner
polizei das abzuwehren den mangelnden
rückhalt in der politik ist übrigens in
anderen ländern ganz anders zum beispiel
meinem heimatland nordrhein westfalen
glücklicherweise herbert reul der steht
hinter seiner polizei unter rüstet seine
position vernünftig aus dass das
nicht immer so dass glorreichen land ich
komme aus nrw ich würde jetzt nicht
sagen das ist das große leuchtende
vorbild herbert oral macht sein bestes
und guten job aber ist nrw ist das land
mit den wenigsten kleinkriminellen nein
überhaupt nicht aber in nrw ist das land
in denen in den letzten jahren das thema
überhaupt man auf die tagesordnung
gesetzt wurde hier in berlin ist man der
auffassung wenn beispielsweise aus der
einen arabischen clans die leute
kontrolliert werden soll das reprofiling
was natürlich hanebüchen der blödsinn
ist aber damit wird die polizei von
ihrer eigentlichen arbeit abgehalten und
in nordrhein westfalen sagt herbert reul
übrigens seit fünf jahren laut
innenminister wir haben zig jahre lang
dieses thema kleinkriminalität dass wir
auch als polizeigewerkschaft immer
wieder bearbeitet haben aber herbert
reul hat es da richtig angepackt mit
personal mit technik mit besseren
polizei gesetzt der luft da kommen wir
doch einmal der frage ansässige co
braucht es in berlin mehr nrw
also ich denke das kann ich jetzt nicht
so gut ich habe wir sind ja auch in nrw
präsent als arche und wir arbeiten in
der regel im brennpunkt und ich sag
jetzt etwas gewagt dass sie können mich
gerne korrigieren ich glaube dass der
ruf der polizei in der öffentlichkeit
eine lachnummer ist also die polizei sie
kam völlig hat keine rechte das ist
ähnlich wie die lehrer die lehrer werden
auch von den schülern ausgelacht die
polizei wird auch ausgelacht weil
letztendlich keiner mehr respekt hat und
wir haben in unserem land wenig moral
wir haben wenig respekt und da braucht
die polizei mehr unterstützung auch von
seiten der politik da muss man
deutlichere sprache sprechen und wenn
eine polizistin ich bin kein polizist
beobachtet dass er selber im trend wenn
ein polizist mal massiv aussagt so hier
ist wirklich stopp ich ziehe meine waffe
dann wird der politisch bestraft und ist
das richtig weiß ich wie gesagt ich will
kein polizeistaat aber die polizei
braucht auch lassen die polizei so wenig
respektiert wenn sie jetzt die
polizeibilder respektiert werden aber
die polizei und da haben sie vollkommen
recht hat keinen rückhalt die polizei
kein rückhalt da wo sie hingehen da sind
sie allein gelassen wenn sie wirklich
mal in eine gruppe gehen und wir zeigen
hier ist die grenze erreicht dann
bekommt zeichen offenbach und ähnlich
ist es mit dem lehrer der die lehrer
haben in unserem land auch ganz wenig
ansehen wenn sie in skandinavien gehen
da ist der beruf des lehrers hoch
anerkannt da ist der bildungsstand auf
viel besser und das eine hat ganz viel
mit dem anderen zu tun wie könnte man
das ändern vor allem vielleicht schon
präventiv bei den familien anfang meinen
kindern naja ich denke das was unseren
kindern heute fehlt ist nicht nur
vernünftige bildung sondern die
rahmenbedingungen dafür dass unsere
kinder brauchen auch kontinuierliche
ansprechpartner und solange der lehrer
in einer brennpunktschule die
eierlegende wollmilchsau ist und er muss
alles leisten hat keine unterstützung
kein psychologe an seiner seite kein
sozialpädagogen nicht mehr menschen die
auch gerade die schwachen schüler
unterstützen und die kinder eine
vertrauensperson haben dann wird es
nicht funktionieren wir sind in einer
stadt von der stadt sozusagen ball
geholt worden da hat man uns gesagt wir
haben hier in unserem in diesem bezirk
wo die arche arbeiten soll eine
straßengang schon in der zweiten
generation die verlangt wege zeigt den
autofahrern
die sind fühlen sich einfach auf wie die
verrückten und wir haben dort eine art
hingestellt und wir waren eben diese
kontinuierlichen ansprechpartner für die
kinder nach fünf jahren gab es eine
polizeistatistik die hat gesagt ist
wächst kein kind mehr in diesen plan
rein weil die arche dort präsent ist mit
menschen die sich um die kinder kümmern
und interessant war dass die ältere die
selbst zudem klagen gehört haben die
jüngeren ihre geschwister die arche
geschickt haben gesagt wir wollen dass
es euch besser geht aber wir hatten
keine perspektive also alles nicht bei
jedem klar aber alles hat auch seine
geschichte und die geschichte müssen wir
hinterfragen und man muss zeit haben
diese geschichte zu hinterfragen und wir
müssen menschen wieder chancen einreiben
und möglichkeiten geben und das passiert
in dieser gesellschaft sehr wenig das
sind schöne beispiele wir wollen einmal
schauen wie der status quo ist und wie
es eigentlich ja wie schlimm eigentlich
das aktuelle problem ist und an dieser
stelle mal vielen dank für ihre arbeit
übrigens jetzige chor und wir schon
einmal rein in die aktuelle lage
der abuja kaplan
der plan hat einen palästinensischen
hintergrund sein oberhaupt arafat abou
chaker der abou chaker clan ist
zahlenmäßig mit mehreren hundert
mitgliedern er das schlusslicht dafür
ist er wahrscheinlich am bekanntesten zu
ihrem zweifelhaften ruhm gelangte die
familie vor allem durch ihre verwicklung
in die deutsch rap szene und arafats
zerwürfnis mit dem rapper bushido dessen
management er lange übernommen hatte
auch der sohn des clan-chefs stand jetzt
vor gericht er wird beschuldigt teil
einer brutalen überfall serie auf
prostituierte zu sein der remote lagen
der plan hat einen arabischen
migrationshintergrund
plan oberhaupt ist ist mit 500 bis 1000
mitgliedern zählt er hier eher zu den
kleinen plans aber unterschätzen sollte
man die großfamilie nicht unter anderem
sollen sie für den einbruch in die
dresdner schatzkammer grünes gewölbe und
den raub der goldmünze aus dem berliner
bode museum verantwortlich sein der
menüplan er kommt aus dem libanon und
ist vor allem in niedersachsen vertreten
plan boss des knie brach im gericht weit
über zwei dutzend türkisch libanesische
familien gehören zu den minis und so
besteht er aus mehr als 1000 mitgliedern
dem clan werden schwere fälle von
drogenhandel diebstahl und hehlerei
vorgeworfen
der alcl ein plan der plan ist eine weit
verzweigte kurdisch arabische
großfamilie der klubboss mohamud als
sein der mittlerweile in der türkei gibt
mehr als 10.000 mitglieder hat der plan
illegale geschäfte mit drogen und waffen
zuhälterei geldwäsche körperverletzung
betrug und diebstahl sollen zur
tagesordnung des all seinen clans
gehören
außerdem soll der plan auch in den
einbruch in die jugendabteilung des
berliner kadewe verwickelt gewesen sein
wenn man das jetzt sieht also die namen
sind bekannt die straftaten sind bekannt
für mich als bürgerin ist es jetzt
wirklich die frage warum greift die
justiz nicht ein dass zunächst einmal
darf man nicht glauben das ist jetzt
eine fest stehende gruppe wäre im
übrigen auch sozialpolitisch völlig
falsch weil man muss neben den ganzen
polizeilichen und justiziellen mitteln
auch
kommunikative und soziale aspekte immer
bereiten hatten das heißt was machen
weil ich mit denjenigen jungen menschen
die in einem solchen klar und einer
solchen familie sind da aber raus wollen
für die müssen wir ein angebot haben den
dürfen wir nicht sagen ja da wird zwar
polizistin oder polizist werden geh du
mal in deinem klar zurück bewohnte ich
hier nicht haben dass genau das nicht
tun haben sie leicht rötlich
lösungsangeboten warum greifen wir da
nicht ein die namen sind bekannt die
polizei greift ein also im übrigen nicht
nur mit polizeilichen mitteln von der
illusion müssen wir uns auch lösen
manchmal ist das finanzamt bei in der
bekämpfung der kriminalität fast so
wirkungsvoll wie ein
spezialeinsatzkommando der polizei oder
ein ordnungsamt oder eine
gesundheitsbehörde eine schulbehörde die
wir alle in der mithaftung nehmen müssen
und das auch tun es findet ja sehr sehr
ausgefeilte konzepte mittlerweile statt
ich habe mich gefreut in neukölln hat
falko liecke beispielsweise das immer
wieder beschrieben seit vielen jahren
ist er damit beschäftigt auch
sozialpolitische ansätze in den schulen
in den familien zu wirken aber eben
nicht nur mit polizei in nordrhein
westfalen werden alle diese behörden
miteinander verbunden es gibt
schwerpunkt kommissariate
schwerpunktstaatsanwaltschaft das genau
der richtige ansatz aber seit einigen
wenigen jahren her diese clans haben wir
seit 30 40 jahren in deutschland wir
werden die nicht in fünf jahren
bekriegen ich glaube da brauchen wir 50
versagt denn hierher frauen ich wollte
noch mal eins nach tragen habe nicht
prinzipiell eine schelte der polizei
einseitig geben wollen es ist auch der
dahinter stehende staat wenn die leute
also die marschieren sofort auch mit
einer reihe von hoch bezahlten anmelden
und wir unsere strafprozessrecht kennt
und all dies weiß dass ein großteil der
leute innerhalb kürzester zeit wieder
auf freien fuß ist strafen folgen nicht
auf dem fuß nach monaten sind
gerichtsprozesse bis dahin ist der
mensch längst dem libanon oder sonst zu
abgetaucht oder deutsch also der staat
versagt man gehe dahin nicht mehr bereit
das heißt diese gesellschaft ich bin ja
dafür dass soziales getan wird im
übrigen es gibt in neukölln nicht zehn
nicht 20 es gibt hunderte tausende
menschen die ihnen mit sozialen bereich
tätig sind die sozialarbeiter sind die
gespräche führen die gruppen therapien
anbieten und alles mögliche das stelle
ich alles nicht in frage aber der staat
zeigt nicht flagge ich habe polizisten
gefragt warum sie nicht eingreifen in
der hermannstraße als der u-bahn
geprügelt wurde da der gesagt meine
kolleginnen nicht gehen hin und dann
haben die fünf zeugen die sagen die
haben gesagt hey ihr [ __ ] brut sodann
wird das aufgeschriebene strafantrag
national profiling [ __ ] brut schon
und die kriegen immer recht so weil die
natürlich zusammenhalten wie pech und
schwefel wir müssen mal die wahrheit wir
haben es noch einmal ganz ganz kleine
historische profiling kein problem also
ist es nicht wirklich so dass ich jetzt
zum beispiel wenn wir jetzt mal ehrlich
sind als blonde frau wahrscheinlich
jetzt nicht direkt kontrolliert werde
und andere schon er gibt es nicht auch
wäsche profiling malerische profilen
gibt es nicht das einzige fall in
deutschland den einzelnen fall gibt es
immer aber es gibt kein strukturelles
problem und es gibt schon gar nicht dass
sozusagen als polizeiliche einsatz
maxime das wird er gelegentlich
behauptet dass polizei wenn sie in
bestimmten gebieten kontrollen vornehmen
in wahrnehmung ihres gesetzlichen
auftrags übrigens und dabei polizeiliche
erfahrung und die augenblick situation
berücksichtigt dann ist das lächerlich
wir sind ja in berlin in einer ganz
anderen situation in berlin macht ja der
gesetzgeber ein gesetz das sogenannte
anti diskriminierungsgesetz da steht
dann drin dass derjenige der behauptet
diskriminiert worden zu sein von der
polizei die polizei dann in die pflicht
versetzt zu beweisen dass sie nicht
diskriminiert hat also völlig absurder
zustand der hier stattfindet aber ich
erlebe das ja immer auch weil er bei der
bundespolizei die in den grenznahen
regionen den gesetzlichen auftrag hat
beispielsweise illegale migration zu
bekämpfen und zu verhindern
und dass sie bei personenkontrollen
nicht erkennbar 80 jährige oma
kontrolliert sondern beispielsweise eine
gruppe die sich auf völlig verhält die
gepäck bei sich hat das zu kontrollieren
ist und sie möglicherweise zu dem
personenkreis gehört der überhaupt in
frage kommt bei der illegalen migration
das sie kontrollieren liegt auf der hand
alles andere wäre übrigens blöd sind und
es würde auch rechtswidrig seien das was
ich gelegentlich aus der politik höre
dass man beispielsweise um rechte
profiling zu verhindern jeder achte oder
zehnte person kontrollieren soll das ist
natürlich völlig absurd und es wäre auch
rechtswidrig denn ich darf niemand
kontrollieren nur weil er die achte oder
zehnte besucher fragen ich einmal herr
siegel co antonia wie finden sie das
also wenn wir racial profiling
entsprechen muss ich schon sagen ich
gucke dann arafat
sciacca an er sieht sehr ähnlich wie
mein vater aus meinem ein israelischer
man sieht auch nicht sehr sehr anders
aus
und ja also mein mann ist komplett
israel ich bin halb deutsch halb israel
in mein mann total israeli wir leben
schon seit fünf jahren in berlin und
natürlich fuld auch mein mann mal sehr
oft dass er anders angeguckt wird
wenn wir jetzt reden warum der staat
versagt hat kann ich nur sagen wir sehen
uns nicht nur ähnlich aber und israelis
wir haben wir kommen auch irgendwie von
eine sehr ähnliche kultur familien
kultur wie wollen wir eigentlich diese
jugendliche oder diese junge männer von
den clans rauskriegen wenn wir den in
deutschland nichts anderes anbieten die
kriegen elisa plan nicht nur gegen
kriminalität die kriegen auch ein
familiengefühl das schon die deutschen
denen nicht anbieten das ist eine gute
frage die wirklich gern direkt an
heilige kuh weitergeben wie wir es
schaffen dass wir sie auch raus holen
ich glaube der ansatz ist nicht man
sollte jetzt auf teufel komm raus
versuchen menschen irgendwo raus zu
holen sondern man muss genügend angebote
schaffen dass jeder mensch irgendwo
hingehen kann wo er sich aufgenommen
fühlt ich bin nicht dafür dass man
gesetze für arme kinder macht ich bin
dafür dass man gesetze für kinder macht
und ich bin dafür dass man angebote
verschafft und das machen wir wir sind
nicht programm orientiert sondern wir
sind beziehungs orientiert ich glaube
das ist das wesentliche das was ich
vorhin schon sagte das vertrauen
aufgebaut werden muss dass man vertrauen
hat bin 27 jahre lang in berlin
hellersdorf ich bin mit der arche
deutschlandweit viele jahre am gleichen
ort aber vor allem mit den gleichen
mitarbeiter mit den gleichen menschen
und das sozialsystem was wir heute haben
man finanziert von einem haushaltsjahr
zum anderen dann werden mitarbeiter
ausgetauscht das fehlen dieser
ansprechpartner die leute die ihnen
bestimmte bezirk und bestimmte gebiete
sind sind entweder ausgebrannt und
schnell weg sie halten gar nicht mehr
durch weil sie nicht das dritte rückhalt
haben und ich glaube das ist wichtig
dass diese ansprechpartner die das
vertrauen der menschen auch der
kleinkinder der klaren jugendlichen
haben die müssen da sein und zwar da
muss was passieren
das ist das was in deutschland
langfristig da sie müssen nachhaltig
haben arbeiten 1 unser konzept und
interessant ist dass jedes kind in jeder
art jeden neuen mitarbeiter in
deutschland ohne absprache fragt wie
lange bleibst du ja heute jeder sagen
doch mit der die projektorientiert
arbeiten und projektorientiert chancen
aus wir wechseln aus wir sind aber keine
keine bank die ihre manager aussortieren
müssen sondern die arbeit mit menschen
väter und mütter sind in der regel auch
über jahre in der familie und erziehen
ihre kinder und unterstützt und das
brauchen wir in unserem sozialsystem
dann wird es funktionieren und das
funktioniert ja seit jahrzehnten in
deutschland nicht aber sie vorher
unterbrechung machen und dann sprechen
wir gleich darüber ob wir mehr härte
brauchen und wie wir mit der
klangqualität umgehen bis gleich
gut nahm meine damen und herren schön
dass sie dran geblieben sind und wir
sprechen nun weiter über die
kleinkriminalität und auch über die
lösung und die erste frage geht an
vehement und zwar über die strukturen
innerhalb der clans welche werte
vertreten sie und wie kann man sich so
eine kleinfamilie eigentlich vorstellen
zunächst einmal als absolut geschlossene
gesellschaft insofern glaube ich auch
nach den vorfällen von duisburg nicht
dass man sich leichter methoden wird die
motive und die hintergründe dieser
schießerei die der stattgefunden hat
aufzuklären weil egal wie verfeindete
sind eins haben sie alle gemeinsam
nämlich mit der polizei nicht zu reden
und staatliche institutionen
strafverfolgungsbehörden die polizei
nicht als solche anzuerkennen die ihnen
irgendwelche autorität vermitteln können
das haben sie alle gemeinsam die polizei
sie hassen die polizei und sie verachten
die polizei auch und verachten auch
diesen ganzen staat und seine
freiheitliche ordnung das haben sie alle
gemeinsam mit der polizei zu sprechen
ist sozusagen ein absolutes no go das
funktioniert überhaupt nicht und deshalb
werden wir sehr schwierig haben und
deshalb kann man beispielsweise in
diesen kreisen auch mit vielen
kriminologischen instrumenten gar nicht
umgehen man keine verdeckten ermittler
dort einschleusen weil man eben dazu
gehören muss sozusagen und weil jedes
familienmitglied auch bekannt ist da
kann man nicht irgendeinen einschleusen
denn er sagt so jetzt schon ein bisschen
klaren mitglied und vom mittels uns hat
informationen sie kennen die szenen er
auch aber er sogar mit welchen zusammen
gelebt als einziger deutscher wie ist
denn das wertet auch mit blick auf die
frauen also das ist ein gutes stichwort
denn er muss 11 ich mir erstmal ganz
wichtig wir reden natürlich das thema
der sendung kleins ich würde ich warne
davor dass wir das jetzt verabsolutieren
ein großteil der menschen die in
neukölln leben müssen wir müssen
glaubens sind sind hoch anständige leute
das ist
aber klar ich würde haben wir meinen
dass deshalb wären draußen kann der
eindruck entstehen davor waren das
möchten wir nicht nein ich möchte das
auch erst aber es gibt natürlich das was
sie beschreiben
die familien dort und das sage ich eine
gewagte these die braucht nicht nur frau
bringt nicht nur freunde ein sind zum
teil viel geschlossener die normalen
familien das familien der
familienverbund spielt eine viel größere
rolle ist auch in asien der fall die
deutsche die eltern also eigentlich
frauen bei der 50er jahre mit
auch noch natürlich mit der frauen
besessenheit hier dass alle sendung
werden in deutschland dominiert von
sieben quatsch thema
ein riesenquatsch thema ich rede über
die ernsthaftigkeit das familien wenn
ich das ist die 50er jahre zurück hervor
so ist zwar ein kleines baby da kann
mich nicht so gut erinnern so also
insofern
ist es so dass also in den familien da
ist der vater ich berichte dass man
schon mal ist ich werde gar nicht
während hier ist der markt der alte hre
ältere opa der alte weiße dumme alte
mann derart von oma zeitgeschichte
wlan-version kultur ich bekomme aus
thailand
in thailand tätig in bangkok da lachen
die nur über so eine kleine schießerei
ja nur meine way so und dann ist die
situation halten wir also auch darüber
lachen müssen wir uns noch vergehen ich
vermute ich mal im nächsten jahr das
duell ist das der anfang aber wir werden
eine situation haben dort ist er wie
unsere gesellschaft bietet keinerlei
identität keinerlei möglichkeiten aus
laptop und konsum und wo liegt die
identität im wertesystem der clans in
welchen familien müssen so wissen sie
was wir überhaupt vernachlässigen das
sind menschen bekommen also einer
anderen kultur und die haben ein ganz
anderes verhältnis zur religion
ich habe mir stunden und nächtelang mit
leuten unterhalten über den islam und
über das frauenbild des islam wie ist
denn jetzt das fragen wir des islams sie
müssen wir die antworten dürfen wir ja
nicht bleiben meinen die werden
gefesselt gehalten und gegen hundenäpfe
hingestellt so stellen sie sich das ja
vor und werden mit großen schwarzen
tüchern umhüllt einverstanden so stellte
es nicht
ehrenmorde
genau bekannt wären rein so dass wir es
so nennen dass wir es einfach so in die
ahs schwer sport ist ein arabia ist
schwer aber
das erst vor kurzem soll ich ihnen sagen
hier kritisiert auf jeden
dritten tag in deutschland wird eine
frau von ihrem ex oder von ihrem mann
ermordet und das dass wir hier in
deutschland in eine westliche demokratie
einfach irgendwas sagen als ob es
wird alle 44 minuten eine vor von einem
mann erschlagen nun mal zu ihrer
information
nein ich will doch weil die immer wieder
bestimmte dass die druckereien die
leuchte eine relativierung und es keine
relativierung wir reden über fakten ja
das übrigens mehr etwas relativieren
ist das auch etwas zu frauen und zwar
ohne ist zu werten wir kritisieren bei
den islamischen familien dass der mann
bis zu vier frauen haben dort das sagen
wir das ist völlig daneben
das sage ich mal was ist denn besser ich
will nicht sagen dass das besser oder
schlechter ist in der bundesrepublik
gehen pro tag 1,5 millionen männer in
bordelle im gesamten europäischen
kulturraum wird sie an 70 milliarden
umgesetzt
die situation lieber erlauben drei
frauen zu haben dann müssen sie keine
damenbinden wesentlich bekannt dass in
diesen ländern wo es mal sein zwangs
positionen gibt wir müssen nicht gleich
immer etikettieren verstehen sie wir
mussten einer frage in einer freien
gesellschaft wie du hast vielleicht
fühlt es sich für viele fragen wie
prostitution an wenn sie vier ehefrauen
sind von einem mannschaft mit solchen
frauen sich nicht unterhalten auf eine
welche selbst
die männer von diesen frauen überhaupt
nicht zulassen dass das ist doch gewesen
erzählt das sind die geschichten die sie
hier auf sich habe in diesen ländern
gelebt mich als journalist mit den
leuten unterhalten ich war in saudi
arabien mehrere wochen das ist doch
alles ein ich verstehen sie ich bin für
toleranz ich sage wenn jemand eine
religion hat die in gewissen bereichen
wollen wir den totalitär unser verfahren
sonst überstülpt die toleranz einmal die
frage ein herr siegel chor weitergeben
wie viel toleranz solche wir haben in
deutschland ja vielleicht schauen wir zu
sehr auf die werte dort herab lieben sie
das einschätzen die debatte also ich
will mich jetzt nicht zu sehr in einer
retten eine ecke zweck lassen aber ich
möchte schon sagen natürlich müssen auch
menschen die in unser land kommen sich
an unsere regeln halten und wir müssen
aber ihnen auch die möglichkeit geben
sich an diese regeln zu halten und
bestimmte dinge vorgeben und wir haben
in den 50er 60er 70er jahren haben wir
versagt in unserem land wir haben gesagt
multikulti macht was ihr wollt und sind
selber schuld an bestimmten strukturen
die wir heute haben wenn ich in der
politik höre wir lassen menschen ins
land die sich nicht registrieren müssen
müssen wir uns nicht wundern dass hier
menschen rein kommen die nicht
registriert sind nun machen dass sie
wollen
natürlich ich will jetzt nicht den islam
hier ein stempel aufsetzen und sagen
alle muslime haben vier frauen und die
sind alle schlecht und sonst irgendwas
ich weiß dass die mütter im islam eine
ganz große rolle in der erziehung spielt
also nicht die väter sondern die mütter
ich habe auch ganz viel mit müttern zu
tun hier sind die christliche
einrichtung und haben trotzdem
massenweise von muslimische menschen die
zu uns kommen und sich auch uns
anvertrauen obwohl wir anders gläubig
sind sag ich mal aber es gibt eben die
extreme und bei den extrem müssen wir
eben gucken wo haben wir für sein ja da
ist sie liegen ja auch ganz wichtig auch
hier für die sendung wir wollen nicht
den islam irgendein voll und ganz klar
und kleinfamilien und die werte in den
clan von
um den islam sondern es geht mir um
einen menschen der versteckt das sind
menschen die versuchen sich anzustrengen
das versuchen sich mühe zu geben denen
man aber nicht unbedingt gesagt hat so
in den 50er 60er jahren du musst jetzt
deutschland ja da fängt ja schon an dass
viele sprechen ja gar kein deutsch die
leben 30 jahre in unserem land und
sprechen die sprache nicht und sprach
ist ja letztendlich auch integration das
heißt da haben sich auch viele gar nicht
integriert das haben wir aber auch
zugelassen wir haben es nicht gemacht
und da liegt der fehler ja dein mann hat
ja in der migrations coole nach da würde
ich natürlich gern wissen wie läuft das
ab wollte ich gerade sagen mein
israelischer man als wir erst zu
deutschland kam musste er einen
integrationskurs machen sei es da auch
mit viele andere migranten und in einem
unterricht hat man ihm beigebracht dass
man seine frau nicht ermorden darf auch
nicht die schwester ja das ist also
wirklich so eingebildet im
integrationskurs war dass manche
teilnehmer überraschend oder es war für
mich überraschend als mein mann das
erzählt hatte ich meine ok dann hat man
schon verstanden dass man diese menschen
wahrscheinlich da zu aufklären muss aber
jetzt zu sagen dass es sehr seriös war
nicht wirklich weil mein mann hat danach
wirklich mitmachen mit seinem syrischen
freund darüber einfach mal diskutiert
hat dann den freund gefragt sag mal wenn
deine schwester jetzt mit einem
deutschen mann geht was machst du und
dann hat er dazu gefragt was heißt es
geht kurz oder was anderes 6 und dann
hat mein mann einfach in verklärung
deine schwester mal sex hat mit jemanden
und dann hat der freund der syrischer
freund gesagt und bringt sie
und er war also das war sein verein kein
scherz es war kein scherz und mein mann
stand einfach da und war total
schockiert
ja das weiß der daraus daraufhin das ist
zumindest einen kleinen teil der markt
klein sein aber einen kleinen teil
derjenigen die zu uns gekommen sind gibt
die man auf diesen umstand aufmerksam
machen muss dass man das eben nicht tun
darf
was nutzen uns aber nichts das mag für
ihren mann ganz seltsam geklungen haben
aber es gibt ganz offensichtlich ein
teil derjenigen
die bei uns sind den man das erklären
muss im übrigen ist das uns ja auch
alles nicht in die wiege gelegt wurde
ich komme aus duisburg ich hab' ich habe
in den 70er 80er jahren lohnt auch
dienst gemacht und deutsche nebenan
erklären müssen dass man seine frau
nicht schlagen darf die der festen
überzeugung waren wieso denn nicht das
ist doch meine frau und das war auch
nicht so ist keine duisburg spezialität
sondern überall ich will nur noch auf
eine differenzierung hinweisen weil sie
gesagt alle reden nur über die plans wir
reden nur über den kriminellen teil der
klappt's ja also es sind hunderte
tausende familien mitglieder profile
ganz normal integriert sind die auch zu
diesem klar zu dieser großartigen aber
eben nicht im kriminellen milieu und
deswegen auch kleinkriminalität selbst
über den kriminellen teil dieser
koexistenz wichtig werden bei der ganzen
diskussion dass wir klar legen dass wir
gesetzt haben und sich an die gesetze
muss man sich halten und egal aus
welcher kultur war kommen du selbst wenn
man aus dem eigenen land kommt den
müssen an uns uns unsere gesetze halten
in unserem land haben und natürlich
kommen menschen in unser land wir haben
einen anderen hintergrund haben eine
andere kultur die haben eine andere
gesetzgebung und sie verstehen manchmal
ich gehe jetzt in ein lockeres land ich
meine muss jetzt auch verstehen es kommt
muslime in unserem land in ein
christliches abendland und sie sehen gar
nichts davon sie sehen gar nichts davon
ja sie sehe ich glaube ein christentum
sie sehen überhaupt keinen judentum muss
sie versuchen ihre also manche versuchen
das mit mit zu uns zu bringen weil wir
für alles offen sind und wer für alles
offen ist es nicht ganz dicht das ist
meine aussage wir müssen auch unsere
regeln vermitteln wir müssen sie aber
auch vorleben ja sie haben vorhin die
lehrer erwähnt und ich muss schon sagen
dass ich manchmal das gefühl habe dass
die lehrer in deutschland sich es auch
ein bisschen leicht machen natürlich es
gibt nicht genug geld es gibt alles als
ja alles ist korrekt aber es gibt auch
schulen in deutschland in den großteil
90 prozent der kinder von einem
muslimischem hintergrund sind und dann
sagen die lehrer zum beispiel wir tun
den holocaust überhaupt nicht wir reden
nicht über den holocaust weil das dann
zu problemen führen kann und jetzt frage
ich wenn wir diese kinder hier in
deutschland aufziehen wollen wenn diese
kinder dann auch wirklich deutsch sein
sollen müssen sie sich ja auch mit der
deutschen geschichte mal
beschäftigen sie haben im gewissen sinne
haben sie recht aber das problem ist
nicht der lehrer das problem ist das
system warum haben wir in berlin klassen
in dem 24 kinder gehen die keine
deutsche herkunft habe und ein deutsches
kind warum verteilen wir diese kinder
nicht auf verschiedene klassen in ganz
berlin wir haben ein kostenloses
nahverkehrsticket und wir haben von
vornherein diese probleme nicht mehr der
lehrer kann das problem nicht lösen der
soll's bestimmten unterricht machen hat
aber 24 gegner gegen sich wie soll der
lehrer das schaffen wenn das system
nicht die möglichkeit schafft dass der
lehrer bessere unterstützung hat der
kann das gar nicht machen und wir wollen
ja nicht den lehrer sozusagen an einem
polizisten an die seite stellen damit er
das überhaupt machen kann deswegen muss
dieses system sich mal überlegen wie
kann ich die probleme in dieser stadt
und auch irgend herausgeforderten
bezirken lösen warum steckt weil ich in
buckow in britz in rudow zwei schüler
pro klasse die aus einer kasse kommen wo
ist nur kinder mit migrationshintergrund
weil jetzt ist doch auch weltweit das
kinder fast immer also neben zu hause
zur schule die versiegelte sie haben
gerade eben ein ganz spannend satz
gesagt und zwar den habe ich mir auch
notiert wer für alles offen ist ist
nicht ganz dicht das würde ich gerne
noch einmal an herrn wendt spielen
diesen satz und fragen ob wir vielleicht
auch einfach härtere regeln brauchen und
jetzt kommt eine schachtel satz den ich
eigentlich nicht machen sondern aber den
mache ich jetzt ist die
migrationspolitik in den letzten 30
jahren gescheitert also dass die
integrationspolitik gescheitert ist
darüber muss man sich in vielen teilen
überhaupt nicht unterhalten sie ist
vielfach geglückt ja aber sie ist eben
auch vielfach gescheitert da wo ganze
stadtteile da sind die im grunde
genommen für deutsche
integrationspolitik fast verloren
gegangen sind so viele menschen sich
auch offen weigern können sich zu
integrieren und ganze gruppen da ist das
gescheitert und es hat viel integrations
romantik in den letzten jahrzehnten
gegeben wo einzelne geglückte fälle
hochgesetzt werden als wäre das
sozusagen die ihr glück für integration
in deutschland und nirgendwo verdrückt
wird dass integration vor allen dingen
auch eine bringschuld derjenigen ist die
zu uns gekommen sind es wird häufig der
eindruck vermittelt als der integration
vor allen dingen eine aufgabe unserer
gesellschaft und war da wo sie nicht
geklappt hat unsere gesellschaft versagt
denn wo immer aus aus migranten dann
kriminalität kommt heißt es die die
gesellschaft die deutsche gesellschaft
hat in ihrer integrationspolitik
versagen ist natürlich blanker unfug war
zur integration gehören immer zwei und
vor allen dingen ist es eine bringschuld
derjenigen die zu uns gekommen sind ist
der erste punkt und
erträge nein ich glaube wir haben schon
gute regeln wir müssen sie nur
durchsetzen und auch anwenden wir können
immer wieder die gesetze verschärfen
können immer wieder schärfere strafen
machen und die justizvollzugsanstalten
vollpacken er sie meinen gemessen
umsetzen wir müssen sie umsetzen und
kommt leider wieder auf mein heimatland
nordrhein westfalen da beginnt man jetzt
gerade damit das umzusetzen aber wir
müssen eben
konsequent dranbleiben das wird nicht in
ein paar jahren gehen und wir müssen da
wo es möglich ist
die leute wir haben die meisten von
denen wir sprechen den ganzen abend
haben wir bereits deutschen pass ich
bezweifle dass das richtig ist
weil der deutsche post gehört an das
ende eines integrationsprozesses nicht
an den anfang aber der zug ist längst
abgefahren aber da wo das nicht der fall
ist müssen bei der begehung von
straftaten und bei dem strafverfahren
auch aufenthaltsbeendende maßnahmen
eingeleitet wird das ist häufig leider
nicht der fall man kann sich manche
strafregister anschauen da fragt man
sich warum sind die menschen überhaupt
noch bei uns warum tun wir uns das
eigentlich an immer wieder
strafverfahren einzuleiten immer wieder
zu bestrafen und niemals sagt jemand du
musst jetzt auch mal unser land voll ist
ab es gibt kein land der welt das sich
so viele stellen sich nicht als solist
es wird natürlich zu wenig abgeschoben
ist ganz eindeutig aus britischen
rücksichtnahme obwohl sämtliche
rechtlichen voraussetzungen vorliegen
war ich der staat immer wieder zurück
auch aus angst vor protesten oder
vorgängen in den eigenen parteien das
ist ganz ganz klar ein straftäter jemand
ein an land kommt hat sich an regeln zu
halten das wurde mir einfach hier betont
wenn die regelverletzung zu regeln wird
gibt der rechtsstaat und man lässt das
also ganz offensichtlich in teilen
gewähren und ich möchten dazu noch etwas
anderes sagen ein staat wird so
wahrgenommen wie er sich gibt und das
führte voraus ich wieder keine wertung
und keinen wunsch uns gilt als
rechtsextrem ich will noch folgende
sagen diese leute kommen aus ländern in
denen nationalstolz vorhanden ist ich
habe leute gefragt wie kommt es dass in
ihrem land die bundeskanzlerin merkel
ich ist die glaub ich bei meinen merkel
16 jahre war sie unsere stadt so lange
war dass ich war viele jahre nicht in
deutschland wissen sie ich habe lange im
ausland fielen usa gelebt die in diesen
jahren aber gott sei dank so der punkt
ist natürlich der dass wenn eine
bundeskanzlerin unsere fahne in die ecke
wirft so in einem offenen widerwärtigen
gefühl fragen sich andere was ist denn
das für ein land leyen hat sind die
fahnen widerwärtigen die ecke geworfen
am abend der bundestagswahl ist jahres
2013 stand sie zwar nun vor ein gutes
ergebnis ein das einzige mal wo sie frau
merkel die stimmen wir bestimmen
steigern konnte von 6 da hat die da
gestanden sind es kam daher grün damals
generalsekretär der christlich
demokratischen union deutschlands und
hat den keilriemen wollen auf den sieg
das ist weg doch mit dem kopf
geschüttelt und ist zur seite gerannt
und hat sie in die ecke geschmissen eine
solche geste wird weder in frankreich
noch in großbritannien noch den usa auch
nur denkbar seien
auch hintergrund
ich bin stolz bürger der bundesrepublik
zu sein um zu sagen ich auch aber durch
den kurz unterbrechen wenn ich mich ja
ein land hat auch etwas mit respekt zu
tun und ich finde dass ein bisschen
anmaßen was ich gerade gesagt wer ein
regal oder eine kurzbahn sie haben über
die regierungschefin dieses landes
gesprochen und abwertend ja was ist das
für ein beispiel in der öffentlichkeit
wenn wir abwertend über regierenden
spender können sie natürlich kritisieren
für das was sie tun wir müssen so zeitig
mit einem 1 machen aber wir sollten
zumindest zu den menschen stehen die wir
gewählt worden sind vielleicht will ich
nicht moment moment vielleicht haben wir
sie nicht gewählt aber ich denke wir
fordern von menschen respekt ein die aus
einem anderen land kommen dann müssen
wir als gute vorbilder vorangehen wenn
ein regierungschef der von der
bevölkerung dieses landes gewählt wurde
in freien wahlen das nationale symbol
die fahne von sich weg würfen ist diese
person nicht geeignet wir uns
nachfolgend zu übernahmen dann stelle
ich fest dass sich die ganz sicher
was ist das denn jetzt nur für den
hintergrund wenn sie wieder weg es gibt
ja es gibt sie ein hintergrund warum man
in deutschland sehr lange nicht einfach
mit der deutschen fahne rum marschiert
hat und ja ich weiß ganz genau und
dritte hätte ich mich auch dazu dass wir
zu dieser geschichte stehen und nie
wieder nie wieder sagen das hat mich
freuen wenn heute in der ukraine
viele deutsche auch so denken würden ja
dass wir das nie wieder zu lassen was
wieder gesagt und ich nicht
zehnmal der sendung sind ja wir werden
ja nicht wir sind im thema wie verbinden
sie das beides zusammen helga france
also sie sagen dass die kleinen
kommentiert auch da ist bei frau merkel
die fahne weggeworfen hat ja weil der
missachtung staatlicher autorität ein
staat der sich selbst nicht achtet kann
auch nicht da gab es schon vor freuen ja
kann auch nicht andere sprache über
einen ganz konkreten umstand und dafür
könnte ihn auch viele beispiele von
zuvor nennen es gibt einfach jedes volk
finde ich für mich ist meine fahrer
etwas schönes die vereine meines landes
für eingestanden werden sie bestraft
wenn sie die anstecken israel dürfte
nicht viel anders sein das war ich noch
nicht um die fahne was ich gesagt habe
ich bemerken es um die fahne wie ich mit
der fahne umgehe so stehst du dem start
in dem ich bin als gewählte vertreterin
was nicht ausreden so ging ist er wie
sie vorher gemerkt
was meinen sie dass ich nicht wusste sie
16 jahre alt ist ich war eigentlich fast
geschafft so kam es zu dem lösungsansatz
damit wollen wir auch eine die sendung
beenden und er hat ein jahr in die damit
schuldigen ist ja wirklich gerne einen
dich antonia übergeben wir haben hier
viele präventionsmaßnahmen auch vor
allem von herrn sie gehört wie die
lösungsansätze sein könnten wie würdest
du denn auch vielleicht blickt wiesen
israel passiert das sehen für
deutschland wie man es schafft dass die
nächste generation nicht mehr in die
kirche eintritt also alles halb israelin
muss ich schon sagen in deutschland sind
die strukturen sehr kompliziert alles in
deutschland ist kompliziert haben sie
vorhin erwähnt die polizei werden was
macht dann kann es aber nicht wegen
diesem grund von justiz und und stadt
man sollte ein bisschen lockerer sein in
diesem land dass erstens zweitens denke
ich schon dass man mir diese also man
sollte mit diesen leuten auch sprechen
also und sie nicht verachten und wenn
wir wollen dass sie deutsche sind sollen
wir sie auch als deutsche behandeln und
das wäre mal für mich wichtig
wie sind sie dafür siege würden sie noch
etwas ergänzen zudem ich glaube dass
wenn wir menschlich sind dann können wir
überall als menschen hingehen ich kann
auch überall hingehen ich kann zu jeder
religion gehe nicht gar nicht wie zu
jedem klar gehen ich muss ein gutes
vorbild sein ich muss authentisch sein
und ich muss das was ich sage auch leben
das ist mir wichtig ich bin christ und
das ist auch gut so ich glaube an gott
und ich kann jedem menschen in die augen
schauen das kann ich und ich glaube wir
brauchen eben diese vorbilder also
spreche jetzt nicht von ihr sondern
überhaupt in unserer bevölkerung wir
brauchen natürlich auch
gesetze die umgesetzt werden und es kann
nicht sein dass ein pädophiler
straftäter
mildere umstände bekommt wenn ein
steuerhinterzieher dafür jahre lang ins
gefängnis geht da müssen wir auch
authentisch zu sein und
ich glaube ja wir müssen alle ein
bisschen darüber nachdenken wie wir in
diesem land miteinander leben können und
das beste rausholen können und dinge die
wir in den nachrichten gehört haben von
clans und von anderen querdenker etwas
was ich muss man im keim ersticken und
zeigen wir haben hier regeln an sie
müssen uns ja frage ich hier nach als
letzte frage an sie herr wendt wie kann
man das denn im keim ersticken also
zunächst mal ist manchmal ganz einfach
wir brauchen wir haben regeln in einer
freiheitlichen demokratie auch in einer
offenen gesellschaft und die muss man
sich halten und wer sich nicht daran
hält muss die sanktionen auch erfahren
dass der staat muss die regelsätze auch
durchsetzen und eins ist auch klar gute
bildung und gute sozialpolitik gute
familienpolitik erspart uns die arbeit
der polizei ersparen sie aber der
politik weil sie verhindert das
entstehen von kriminalität auch dafür
gibt es schon gute beispiele in baden
württemberg in nordrhein westfalen den
anderen ländern gibt es gute beispiele
wo justiz sozialarbeit und polizei
schulen ganz frische und
zusammenarbeiten und da wird das aus
verhindert das ist möglich aber man
braucht den staat der das macht man darf
es nicht outsourcen an private immer
wieder private gesellschaft die
rahmenbedingungen die rahmenbedingungen
müssten diejenigen die diese arbeit
machen und zwar nicht nur bei polizei
und justiz sondern auch in der sozial-
ab müssen auch beruflich langfristige
perspektive und anständige
arbeitsbedingungen haben da sind wir
auch motiviert und leisten gute arbeit
und dann wollen wir mal kriminalität
übrigens nicht nur kleinkriminalität und
damit herzlichen dank an meine runde wir
sind schon zum ende angekommen ich würde
sagen wir müssen sehr bald eine sendung
zur deutschlandfahne machen und da werde
ich sie zu einladen herger vor vielen
dank für den themenvorschlag das werden
wir machen und ich wollte sie noch bitte
schauen sie sich doch mal die
organisation an die machen tolle sachen
vielleicht wollen sie sich mal anschauen
was sie so tun und damit wünschen wir
noch einen schönen abend und wir sehen
uns dann nächste woche dienstag wieder
weil für die nach acht machen sie es gut
und bis bald
[Musik]